now I'm going to walk you through the
process of getting your workspace set up
on Windows
there are also written instructions in
the instructors notes if you're using
Mac or Linux you should skip to the next
video first I'm going to configure get
bash to use a white background if you
prefer to use a dark background you can
skip this step I'll click this icon
select defaults and go to the colors tab
then I'll set the screen background to
white and the screen text to black then
I'll close and reopen git bash and the
screen is white now next I'm going to
download two files that are needed for
the setup I showed you earlier one to
enable tab completion and one to enable
the get features in the prompt the links
to these files are in the instructors
notes to download each file I'll visit
the page right-click anywhere on the
page and select save as I'll save the
file to my downloads directory next I'll
use git bash to move the file to my home
directory my home directory is where I
start out when I open get bash or I can
move to it by typing CD tilde if I need
to now I'll use the command M V which
stands for move to move the file I just
saved to my home directory the first
argument is the file I want to move
which is in my downloads directory and
it's named get completion dot dash dot
txt now the dot txt was created by the
web browser but I don't actually want
that so I'll choose the name get
completion dot bash as the new name and
without specifying a directory it will
automatically get saved to my current
directory then I'll go through the same
process to save the second file in the
instructors notes as get prompt Sh next
I'm going to create a file called dot
bash profile which contains
configuration forget bash I recommend
using the configuration file that I used
when filming this course to do this you
can download the file called bash
profile course in the downloadable
section then use git bash to move the
file from your downloads directory or
wherever you downloaded it to to your
home directory and name it dot fash
underscore profile don't forget the dot
at the beginning of the name if you
already have a bash profile then don't
run this command instead you can copy
and paste the content from my bash
profile into your existing one if you
like
I don't see any changes to my prompt yet
and that's because I'll need to close
and reopen get - before the changes take
effect I'll do that at the end of the
video in case you're curious about
what's in this batch profile or if you'd
like to pick and choose which lines to
keep I'll go through what each line does
don't worry if you don't understand how
each line works though even experienced
UNIX programmers frequently copy and
paste this kind of thing from their
friends rather than writing it from
scratch this first line loads one of the
files you downloaded earlier and enables
tab completion these lines define some
colors which will be used in your prompt
this line loads the other file you
downloaded earlier and it's necessary
for the get related stuff like commit
IDs to show up in your prompt this line
makes it so that an asterisk will show
up in your prompt if you change
something in a git repository and this
line sets the prompt it will show you
username in purple the commits you have
checked out and other get related stuff
in green and the directory you're
currently in followed by a dollar sign
in blue anything after that will be
displayed in the default color if you're
curious to learn more about how prompts
work in bash
check out the link in the instructors
notes but it's not necessary for the
rest of this course
now I'll configure get to use sublime as
my editor for things like commit
messages you'll want to configure get to
use whatever editor you like but the
process should be similar first I'll
need to figure out where sublime was
installed for many people this is under
C Program Files sublime text - and
that's the case for me if it's not here
you might also try looking under see
Program Files x86
then I'll run the command git config - -
global coordinator followed by the text
editor that I want to use in double
quotes for me this is sublime and I'll
need to specify the full path to sublime
but for now I'm just going to type
sublime as a placeholder followed by - n
- W the - n means sublime will open in a
new window and the Dodge W means get
will wait for you to close sublime
before trying to continue now I'm going
to replace the blaim with the full path
to sublime in single quotes starting
with the directory you saw earlier and
then I'll add sublime text Exe I know
you can't see the whole command here you
can copy and paste it from the
instructors notes
although you'll have to modify it if
sublime is installed in a different
location for you or if you're using a
text editor or other than sublime it's
also a good idea to make sure you can
launch your text editor from within get
bash I'll show how to do this for
sublime if you use another text editor I
recommend you use Google to figure out
how to launch it from within get bash
I can already launch sublime within get
bash by typing the full path to it but
I'd like to have a shortcut to create
one I'm going to add a line to my bash
profile using sublime now opening the
badge profile is going to be a little
tricky because anything with a dot at
the beginning of the name is a hidden
file and it won't show up in most file
system explorers to get around that I'm
going to temporarily rename the file to
not have a dot at the beginning of the
name then I'll change it back once I'm
finished then I'll open up sublime and
open the file I'll navigate to my home
directory under computer C users see
Bucky and then I'll select the bash
profile then I'll add this line to
create a command called subl which will
open sublime if you use sublime you can
copy and paste this line from the
instructors notes although again you
might need to modify it to be the
location sublime as installed for you
note that this command also won't work
until you close and reopen git bash now
that I'm done I'll rename the file to
have a dot at the beginning of the name
again if I didn't do this then this file
won't automatically be loaded when git
bash starts up next I'll run two more
git config commands that will come in
handy later this course I'm going to run
them now so that all the configuration
advice for the course will be in one
place you can copy and paste these
commands from the instructors notes
finally I'll close git bash and reopen
it now I can see that my prompt has
changed and if I want to view my bash
profile using sublime I can run double
dot bash profile remember to close and
reopen git bash when you're finished or
your changes won't take effect